[Music]
a series of more perfect union aims to
show that what unites us as americans is
far
greater than what divides us this
morning our senior medical correspondent
dr
taran narula shares the story of a
cardiologist in nashville is healing
people through the power of medicine
who saves lives as a transplant
cardiologist
i meet people who are basically dying
from heart failure
and with transplant we can you know give
them their lives back
and is breaking barriers with a second
career as an acclaimed
singer-songwriter
[Music]
you don't know the battles people are
are fighting and i feel that way a lot
sometimes it's hard for people to know
all you're going through just under the
surface
susie says she discovered her love of
music in med school
and today it's what keeps the doctor mom
and wife
balanced it was the only way i had found
to express my vulnerability and to
express some of these parts of myself
that i couldn't at work
and the loneliness i was feeling as a
career woman
having to act tough all the time why do
you feel as a doctor
you can't express your vulnerabilities
as it is there aren't a lot of female
cardiologists
and i felt like i needed to be taken
seriously
[Music]
but music has taught me the importance
of being vulnerable and i'm absolutely
so much more vulnerable
at work with my house staff and with the
patients
she's my hero one of those patients is
jenny thomas
a few years ago jenny developed
cardiomyopathy a heart condition that
required a heart transplant
she credits much of her recovery to dr
brown
i didn't even realize how talented she
was and then
found out that she too had a singing
career along with being a cardiologist
and a mom
and she just wears a lot of hats
jenny believes music makes her an even
better doctor
and susie agrees it gives me more
strength to have the hard end-of-life
conversations
and to handle all the sadness and still
be strong
for the family and for the patient and
my team sometimes you
find your dreams when do you feel the
most like you
the most free the most free is when i'm
singing
and i also feel the most like me when
i've made a really good call at work
when a patient comes in and says like i
don't know how i'll ever repay you
you know so i just feel lucky that um
that i can do it all
and for her that means dividing her time
between the hospital
the studio and home what are you going
to teach your children
from what you've learned there are no
rules it's all just made up that you
have to work full-time in medicine
and you can't do other things what
matters is that you're happy
and i like to say if you're happy you
win i've been
trying for cbs this morning i'm tara
narula
in new york love everything about you
susie wearing a lot of hats and wearing
them all very well